a este punto ya se han agotado todas las
opciones para evitar una extradición que
hará la defensa
si no no se han agotado en absoluto no
se han agotado en absoluto estamos
todavía no estamos en el final del
camino pero lamentablemente nos estamos
acercando a ese final no nos esperábamos
de esta decisión de la corte de
finalmente revertir lo que ya una corte
de menor nivel había hecho es decir
impedir la extradición de julian assange
por las razones humanitarias de su salud
del riesgo al suicidio y de las
condiciones opresivas ultra opresivas
del sistema carcelario norteamericano
para los casos de espionaje en todo caso
quedan todavía algunos recursos dentro
del propio sistema legal británico y
existe una opción que se llama la
apelación cruzada que todavía no han
activado los abogados de julian assange
que es básicamente apelar a varios de
los puntos que una primera instancia no
le fueron concedidos a la defensa entre
esos
publicar no es un delito no puede haber
extradición por delitos políticos
segundo julian assange's no tendría en
ningún caso un juicio justo en eeuu su
defensa su defensa legal su estrategia
legal ha sido sujeto de espionaje por
las agencias de inteligencia de eeuu que
además tiene una palabra mayor en las
condiciones carcelarias que tendría en
eeuu
toda esa serie de cosas no han sido
todavía peladas pueden apelar se
independientemente de la decisión
política que haga la ministra del
interior que tiene en sus manos de este
momento la posibilidad de parar esa
extradición un paralelo podemos recordar
en el caso de augusto pinochet donde las
cortes decidieron su extradición pero el
poder político nos la detuvo
ahora señor narváez usted mencionaba que
no sería un juicio justo en eeuu pero
cuál sería el futuro de julian assage en
caso de ser enjuiciado en este país y
cuando podría ser extraditado si es que
llega a darse esta medida
bueno no sabemos cuánto puede durar
todavía la batalla legal dentro del
reino unido porque además de las
distancias que quedan dentro del sistema
jurídico británico todavía queda la
opción de la corte europea de derechos
humanos
que en ocasiones ha negado ya
extradiciones hacia los eeuu entonces no
sabemos cuanto más pueda y pueda durar
esto si se alargue un año más qué sé yo
pero el futuro de julián en eeuu es es
es la muerte básicamente es una muerte
en vida porque están pidiendo para el
175 años nada más por publicar la verdad
algo a lo que en este momento se oponen
la totalidad de organizaciones por la
libertad de expresión y por los derechos
humanos en todo el mundo este es un caso
netamente político y es lamentable que
además coincida con un conflicto bélico
político geopolítico que me imagino que
influye también en en la decisión de los
jueces